here's what I was thinking
now's a great time to get into Rick and
Morty
what's up never heard of it you saw what
Adult Swim said should I binge it you
said what do you which should I start
like right at the beginning or should
what's up okay all right all right I got
it I got a guy shut up shut up I got it
there's an episode that there's a really
funny episode that you could look the
creators Justin Roland just Google
Justin Roland miners
okay it's an episode let's see what
comes up hang on
Wow a lot it even has the Google uh the
the things you're a lot being said about
this right now yeah warning um it's
trending so it must have been it's
trending so it must have been a good
episode yeah is that the show with a guy
is it was a pickle or something that's
like a pickle but he's also a scientist
but my joke he's in a pickle
I'm in a pickle Rick I'm in a pickle
Morty
I'm probably going to jail for a long
time
hey Martin hey hey Morty hey Morty I'm
I'm a sexual predator of sex best Rick
let's Rick people don't really like
sexual predators oh geez oh Rick why did
you have to yell at her that she was
jail being those texts Rick oh God all
right hear me out on this Morty all
right do me a favor I need you to stack
that jury with a bunch of Rick and Morty
fans
oh jury notification Morty it's my only
hope Oh My Story number three I don't
really know sometimes you just gotta you
just gotta you gotta tell a [__] twice
Marty I saw that episode I saw that
episode Ricky Rick becomes a Libertarian
sometimes you love a woman so much you
sometimes you live over so much you just
gotta hit her Morty you gotta hit her in
the face
I gotta go I'm already I gotta go talk
to 14 year olds on telegram yeah why are
they jailbreak morning I feel you're
just taking advantage of them Rick I
just what's the point Marty don't you
get it you get famous I feel like you're
taking advantage of the power Dynamic
what's the point what's the point of a
power Dynamic Morty if you can't take
advantage of it if you would have told
me a show with Dan Harmon as one of the
creators and he's not the one that got
in trouble for this I wouldn't believe
you that it was the other guy that's the
weirdest part yeah I know Dan Harmon's
now sitting back like huh not so bad now
I'm just an obnoxious drunk exactly
hardest guy in the room
not [__] molesting kids beating women
so Adult Swim said they're going to
continue the show but they're not with
Justin but he does like all the voices
so then what's the show
what's the show no because even if they
find people that go through the voices
the same it's the guy's show so just
stop the show right listen we hear a fox
are disgusted with the recent
allegations against Seth MacFarlane so
the Family Guy and American Dad will be
moving forward without him all right all
right guys all right guys so we're gonna
do Rick and Morty without Justin Roiland
so hear me out Dan Harmon presents and
no I can't
so this Show's just called and
everyone else oh to to repurpose a joke
Dan Harmon is the and in Rick and Morty
yes
oh no uh um be careful don't make fun of
him too much he might change his
production logo to him sad divorced on
the couch again [__] miserable
bastard